[Music]
car TV gets inducted into the Kardashian
crew the new mama joined Kim Kardashian
and Kris Jenner for a quiet night in at
Kim's pad which of course led to a
number of fun social media posts
including this clip of the trio trying
out a new filter how do I like a
different birthday
hurry up did for a green and blue
Balenciaga track jacket for the occasion
and once again showed off her new blue
wig meanwhile Kim rocked a tan
sleeveless top which she paired with a
white fanny pack like many nights with
the Kardashian family where they tried
on a variety of masks and posed it up in
front of the mirror
we're just late night in the closet
looking absolutely stupid both Chris and
cardi took to Instagram with the same
selfie from there hang the 62 year old
Jenner captioned hers late-night
shenanigans at home while cardi wrote I
am officially a part of the rich people
club I'm not poor anymore
mwah-ha-ha-ha PS I'm selling one of at
Kris Jenner napkins on eBay
[Music]
[Applause]